the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints will build 18 new houses of the
Lord in the coming months and years Las
Vegas is one of those locations that is
where we find Mary Jane beliesa right
now she is live in northwest Valley near
Lone Mountain where the new Temple is
set to be built Mary Jane
good afternoon to you Christian that new
Temple is set to be built here on the
slot on Alexander and Grand Canyon
members tell me that this new location
will not only serve those living in this
part of the valley but can help serve
those living as far as Pahrump and other
Southern areas
and we thought there's no way there's no
way we're gonna get this
and I still get charged up thinking
about it I just started to cry annalize
Castor a member of the Church of Jesus
Christ of Latter-day Saints is overcome
with the motion of the announcement of a
new Temple in the Las Vegas Valley a lot
of real enthusiasm and but everyone at
one point kind of settled and it all
just kind of settled in your heart how
grateful we were and it was not lost on
this that this announcement came five
years from the day that October 1st
shoots happened the temple will be the
fourth Latter-Day Saint Temple in Nevada
the first one in Las Vegas opened in
1989 at Bonanza in Hollywood there is
one in Reno with plans to open another
in Elko Las Vegas has a lot of heart you
know we've raised our family here
Michael Gardner the Latter-Day Saints
stake president for the sky Canyon area
says this Temple is a big symbol to
Showcase how much the community has
grown in the last three decades having
the temple is that emblem it's that
signal to us as a people is God's
children not just members of the church
but the community as a whole church
members anticipate more information to
come in the next few days including
renderings and when construction will
start this Temple is for everybody that
the hope is that you know people will
feel the blessings of having a temple
not everywhere is allowed temples you
there's certain parameters and things
that are required and we were already
lucky enough to have one temple in our
Valley but let alone to have two
members say once construction is
complete and before the temple is
dedicated there will be an open house
where the public can check out the
temple reporting live in the Northwest
Valley Mary Jane valleza 8 News Now